Yeah,
I think the thing about now is it's a real test for the media for
journalists and reporters like me on like stick to the facts, to the,
to the data, follow the experts, follow the election commission nerves,
and all the people that actually putting this on,
on the ground instead of trying to guesstimate. Um, I think, you know,
there are places where president Trump over-performed or Biden,
underperformed, um, Florida being one of those places, right?
That was when you talked about an unexpected result. Um,
that was when they were feeling kind of confident about,
but the thing that Biden and when he talked to Biden people now,
even late last night,
when things started looking kind of shaky is that this is what they were
actually expecting for months. We kept hearing that, you know,
this is going to be a blowout, you know, political did not say that, um,
this is going to be a blowout. Um,
there's going to be a huge repudiation of president Trump.
That is not what we have seen. I think,
no matter what happens with this election at the end of the day,
president Trump was able to convince enough people in this country that their
lived experience, right? Their lived experience during a pandemic,
during a recession is not reality, right?
Like he was able to convince people that, you know, COVID-19,
we're rounding the corner and I handled it well, you know,
this is the best economy I've done.
I had the best economy and the best for black people,
I'm the best about you and them, the best for women. Um,
he was able to convince them of that.
And what that means is that the Republican party may not even if Trump loses the
Republican party is not going to just, you know,
wash their hands of Trumpism. Right. In a way that Joe Biden, I think,
was hoping something in that Andrew Yang said, um, to me before, is that,
you know, Trump during the primary,
that there are some of the people running,
I think he was talking about Joe Biden that think that president Trump is like,
um, uh, an interlude, right? Like he is, he is,
he is a symptom of the profits of phase. Right? Exactly.
And that is clearly not the case, right?
Like if there had been this huge repudiation around the country, um,
and huge numbers of president Trump,
if all of the early vote wasn't just to Joe Biden,
that's what we would have been saying, but that's not the case.
And I think how this country wrestles with that is going to be fascinating and
scary for a lot of people for, for, for, you know, at least maybe a decade.
I think.
I feel like your predictions were probably pretty close to Zach and I used to be
on terms, but I'm curious, really curious as to, you know,
what, um, you know,
there was one or many predictions going into election night that you were
personally surprised by seeing as an outcome.
Yeah. I'm surprised about Georgia.
Georgia is still really close in a way that I really,
I just never believed that, um, you know,
Democrats were going to be able to really play there.
And I think they are showing that something's happening in Georgia, Florida.
The Latino vote in Florida is really surprising Miami, Miami, hello,
the underperforming by Joe Biden, there is surprising to us.
And also I think can super concerning for Democrats moving forward because there
have ever since, you know,
ever since he was the general election candidate that Joe Biden, um,
and the nominee though, you talked to Democrats and 40 tux and Latino activists,
and they say he needs to focus on Latinos a lot more.
He needs to focus on Latinos a lot more and they didn't really take that
seriously. They started to do that toward the end,
but it was clearly not enough. Right. And that is something that, you know,
you look at the people that were at the DNC, um, them Castro,
not there, you know what I mean?
Like people that huge Latino names were not a part of that
process and a part of that pageantry and that matters.
And I think it showed that it mattered in Florida more than Democrats thought it
was important. There were so many.
The only way I can explain them to just be S media narratives that came out of
the, the hype up this election and I'll get political credit.
They weren't fueling the fire anywhere near as much as some of maybe the
broadcast networks and things like that. Um, but we all got wrapped up in it,
um, and self included, but it was, um, in some, in some ways,
but there were narratives like Texas is in play and I was in
play and South Carolina is in play and the narratives were fueling these, uh,
frankly down-ballot candidates too. Um, and there were like, look,
Jamie Harrison,
who's the guy who was running against Lindsay Graham raised more money than he
could ever more than we did on the presidential campaign.
And we raised a lot and there were polls showing him close to
Thomas winning and then like literally could not have been further from the
truth. Like they called it on election night, um, pretty early. So.
What, what.
Is the media missing, um, from your angle? You know what I'm saying? Like,
what is it polling? Is it headlines that clickbait what's driving this?
I, you know, the,
I, I'm lucky to work at political, a place that doesn't, you know, some,
you know, we don't always get it right.
Even I know that there's not that I'm going to come to him by and then click
baity things. Um, but there is so much,
the media issue is that we are obsessed with the drama. We are drama Queens.
We are messy people who love drama.
That is like at the core of what it seems like is driving a lot of the media
narrative and the media conversation is that, you know, um,
we take one thing, one poll, a couple of polls happening in one state.
And we pull that out to me like, Oh my God, the election is,
the election is not even close. This is going to be a blowout. Um,
it's dangerous. It is, you know,
at times really it's disconcerting for democracy because
if there isn't a media that can understand the people, right? Like if there's,
isn't a back and understand how people are feeling in this country,
we're kind of screwed. Right. I think that we, I think more times than not,
we get it, we are correct. Right. Like I think all the reporters I know,
and the more I'm in this business, the more I get to meet him,
the bigger names I know that feels like a brag. It kind of is a humblebrag.
I guess I get to meet, I get to meet you at the same thing. Yeah.
Like you meet more important people who have been doing this for a really long
time. And so I,
I have never met a reporter that like just likes the drama,
like the drama or isn't, doesn't take this part of their job really seriously.
Right. Understanding the American people. Um, and that's key.
And I think that part is what we're losing. The polling industry is doing. Uh,
I'm going to get in trouble for this one as a public industry.
Sometimes it's doing a better job of kind of explaining what they got wrong.
They kind of getting things. Right. And so, um, in 2016,
a lot of the surprise that we had was that there was, you know,
they didn't wait for education in this country.
And if you were someone who was watching 2016, as much as I was as a reporter,
you could tell that something was happening with people without white people,
without a college degree. Right. That,
that was something that was happening with president Trump and that.
And so doing that, understanding the different demographics,
understanding that Latinos are not a monolith that black people are not a
monolith Asian-Americans are not a monolith. Um,
it's going to take more money and more resources in a way that, you know,
in this media environment where there's still, there's only so much money,
right. And there's only so much you only ways to make money. Um,
that investment is going to be really intense and should be really intense over
the next years to kind of figure out what's going on in this country,
because we are out an,
it feels like we're at an inflection point in this country and which I don't
think, you know, many of the reports I haven't seen, I'm 31. Um,
and that most reporters I've talked to, who've been doing this for much longer.
I haven't seen either.
Um, or go ahead, Eric, if you're going to say some, sorry.
No, I, I think that, I think that's excellent insight and, you know,
kind of thinking about, uh, a couple of things directly, um,
that we've had a chance to kind of review, uh, over your reporting.
You talked about, uh, the black vote, um,
and both Trump and buying, getting it wrong. Um, you know,
in terms of race in this election, you know, obviously,
and Zach has mentioned this as well in terms of folks talking about, uh,
the democratic side and using Trump, being racist, uh, as a narrative,
it didn't really seem to stick. And we looked at the map here. And what,
just kind of curious about some of your thoughts on that.
Yeah. I think the thing that, um,
Democrats do Republicans do, um,
in elections is they hope that one message works for everyone that looks
similar. Um, they hold these that way easier.
If you spend less money and, you know, on a, on a kind of cynical level,
like that makes sense. Right. Um,
and you in this country where we have the socioeconomic
status of people being so huge and the way they see and think about the world,
um, where they live, the kind of access to healthcare, their access to, um,
you know, discretionary spending, those kinds of things.
You're getting a split in a lot of places, right?
Like obviously Trump was never going to win the black vote.
But if the only argument to black people is Donald Trump is a
racist. You're not going to win that. Right.
Like I talked to a lot of black people throughout the year, um, who,
what I kept hearing, um, whether they were activists or just like normal people,
um, was that, yeah, white people are racist. You know what I mean? Like that,
they just like, think that. And so it's like, okay, so if everybody's racist,
why would I go vote for anybody? And so you have Joe Biden who,
the author of the 1994 crime bill that disproportionately impacted black men in
this country. Um, you know, you have, so, you know,
even this year when he was kind of, you know,
remembering the good old days in the Senate where he worked with segregation,
if you like name checks, some people who had terrible views about black people,
these are things like if you put those two candidates up against each other,
there are black people in this country who are, I've talked to,
there's a lot of reporting on this though. They're like, yeah,
you're all kind of the same. You know what I mean?
So you have to give them something else.
You have to give them something that is, um, you know,
what are you going to do for me? How do you make it better? And I think,
you know, we started seeing like ice cube one little Wayne,
like kind of coming out very strange way. Look. Um,
but the thing that's really the funniest one,
just watching that frenzy about around that proved that the
media and Democrats see black people as a democratic. When would you think,
why would we think little Wayne or ice cube are Democrats?
They have never told us we don't know that. And so like, they were like,
Oh my God, why is little Wayne with Donald Trump? Right.
Maybe he's a Republican. We don't know. He also can't vote because he's a felon.
You know what I mean? So like, I actually don't know. And so there's this,
there, there are all of these, um,
our personal biases and unders misunderstanding of, um,
groups of people that feed into all of this and it pops up. Um, and,
and Twitter is the worst.
Like Twitter is the place where all of that is happening the most, you know,
it's just like, it is a cesspool of,
of an echo chamber of an echo chamber of an echo chamber.
Like most Americans aren't on there. Um,
and I think that's Democrats, you talked about like, you know,
them getting excited about Texas or Georgia and all of those things that happen,
but a lot on Twitter, right? Like that,
and you allow Twitter to run your campaign.
You're kind of screwed because that's not where like,
real Americans are quote unquote real Americans. But I mean, like, you know,
like the average Americans, not right Hillary, the Hillary campaign,
one of the criticisms there was that they were too much listening to the echo
chamber. It seems like the Joe Biden campaign did not, has not done that. Right.
We'll see how the numbers shake out,
but it looks like they played a game that was based on what they knew to be
true. Right. The Midwest was important.
He had a chance in Arizona in a way that Democrats haven't had in a very long
time, um, and ignored. He didn't go to Texas. They sent comma hair.
It's kind of in the last days, um, he did not go to Texas.
They spent a lot more money in Georgia. You know what I mean,
than Democrats have before. Um, but they, they weren't trying,
they weren't concentrating so much on expanding the map,
just using pipe dreams that Democrats have on how humongous States like
Texas would go just off of demographics.
Because just looking at demographics, you don't know how voters are going to.
The, one of the things I thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.